i'll be home in the morning where are
you going i'm staying over at susie's
tonight
what's new
the flyer
the papers call him the grabber i wish
you wouldn't call man you don't actually
believe that story do you because he
can't hear you and he doesn't really
take kids that safe
oh
you goof beautiful isn't that just
peachy cute you need some help you see
that
would you hand me my hat
yes sir
i
am a part-time magician
are those type of loans in there
would you like to see a magic trick
i have an announcement to make one of
our students finney blake was abducted
what if i could help the police find
penny
[Applause]
[Music]
doesn't work
not since i was a kid
i'll scream i'll scratch your face
this face
daddy i had a dream about him what
happened in your dream he was taken by a
man with black balloons yes we never
release those details
huh
don't hang up who are you
you know all her names
you're getting out of here
please please let the dreams be real see
the in front of you i tore a long cable
loose from down there
there's a combination lock i'm the
inside of the storm door what's the
combination
[Music]
i carved it in the wall
the tree the door the gate i've never
seen you before except in my dream
you don't have much time
you're gonna use a weapon you raise the
phone step back and swing
look what you made me do
please hurry you remember what i told
you
there's someday i have to stand up for
myself someday it's today finn
you